[Musique]
en ukraine il y à la ligne de front dans
l'est du pays alors que dans l'ouest des
villes comme olivier vous je me trouve
servent de base arrière c'est vraiment
un endroit où circulent des milliers de
déplacés se coordonne l'aide médicale le
transport de blessés où sont produits
des biais aussi qu'ils sont destinés aux
militaires qui sont au front donc c'est
vraiment un endroit privilégié pour être
témoins de l'effort de guerre de la
société ukrainienne mais aussi de sa
résilience une société qui essaie malgré
tout malgré la guerre de continuer à
fonctionner
premier matin de tournage on s'est rendu
à la gare de l'hiver où on pensait
peut-être rencontrer des ukrainiens qui
tente de retourner à kiev avec le
retrait des forces russes finalement on
est tombé sur le quai de la gare sur une
équipe de médecins sans frontières qui
avec des caisses de matériel et on
apprend qu'un trait qui a été converti
en hôpital est sur le point d'entrer en
gare résultat on était capable de
visiter ce trailer qui sert à
transporter des blessés de l'est de
l'ukraine vers l'ouest où les hôpitaux
sont moins débordé c'est un bel exemple
de l'ingéniosité mais aussi du courage
des travailleurs humanitaires qui sont à
l'oeuvre dans le pays souvent les
meilleures histoires sont celles qui
arrivent à l'improviste
ya la barrière de la langue qui est un
défi quand on recueille des témoignages
parce que quand pour faire des entrevues
on essaie vraiment d'établir un lien
avec la personne qui nous parle qui nous
partagent parfois des histoires qui sont
très très difficile heureusement on a
avec nous un traducteur très talentueux
qui a beaucoup d'instinct qui nous aide
justement à bien comprendre à bien mener
ces entrevues là autre défi c'est au
niveau du tournage je vous dirais parce
que dans un pays en guerre on ne peut
pas nécessairement fini mais ce que l'on
souhaite les militaires ici ne nous
laisse pas par exemple films et des
infrastructures qui serait stratégique
du point de vue militaire alors il faut
essayer de naviguer laddh
j'ai été très touché par une rencontre
avec deux étudiantes en arts visuels ici
a living qui m'ont expliqué leur besoin
et leur désir de continuer à créer
malgré cette période de conflit une
façon pour elle de montrer que la nation
ukrainienne existe qu'elle est encore
bien vivante l'une d'elles me disais que
jamais elle ne s'est sentie aussi
ukrainienne que depuis le début de
saison
[Musique]